first of all thank you for the fashion
moment sir i don't get to give that to
the men much but you gave us a three
piece that means the world man
it's bespoke this is me um my wife just
happened to put on a
you know turquoise and blue dress so
we're coordinating so it feels good
listen i feel comfortable i feel great
now you and i talked last week about you
being the ultimate girl dad yes
father's day is coming up look at that
christopher bridges and the bridges
girls yes come on man
come on i didn't even that was on cue i
didn't even know he was going to say
anything
then i just had to do that bam father's
day is on sunday
yeah what does daddy want daddy wants to
be by his damn cell phone father's day
excuse me for saying that i'm just going
to keep it real i think all fathers just
want to ride in the car by their damn
cells for like five
hours and not have to worry about
anything and like that's how i feel
i love it no listen if that's what you
want to do you should be able to do it
on father's day that is so hilarious now
listen you guys are going to be
on stage together as a family for the
first time in a really long time
celebrating this movie and welcoming
people back to the theaters how
important is it for people to see
this movie in a movie theater it's a
it's a moviegoers event everybody is
coming back not just here in the states
but all over the world and i'm glad to
be a part of a franchise
that can actually make people want to do
that we made this movie for people to
watch it inside of the theater
at a time where streaming is all-time
high people don't have to leave the
comforts of their home
this is literally what it's all about
and it's just the timing couldn't be
more perfect
um the stakes have you know been raised
there's more action in this
we've put everything our entire soul's
energy
into making a movie that we know
everybody's gonna be proud of and you
know family hits home more than ever and
it's tested more than ever in this film
okay so you know i've seen the movie so
we got to talk about that post-credits
scene
we see jason statham
we see jason statham we do he's only
been gone like one movie what do you
mean
i honestly did not think he would be
back when we see that we're like
with this franchise you always surprised
that who may or may not come back so you
just we're just full of surprises
so then what are we doing in in the 10th
movie are we really trying to get
justice for han is that what we're going
for
not only are we trying to get justifying
but you almost got me
i can't really talk about what the hell
is going on in 10. otherwise somebody
will come tackle me right now
it's uh i have to remain silent i cannot
listen if somebody else wants to spill
the beans
hopefully they will but i can't do that
i'm not getting fired i will say
justin did give me a little and he said
he even is the only person that could
probably do that please tell me what
justin said because i don't even know
justin said that the audience wants
justice for han
and they don't feel like he doesn't feel
like it was achieved
in this movie so that there is work
still to be done
sung said the same thing there's work
still to be done
wow they told it they told it
but that that becomes a problem because
the fans love jason statham as well so
we don't know what's going to happen
there
you got me in suspense i have no idea
what's going to happen okay you must be
the homeboy still in outer space then if
you know nothing
i really don't know i promise you i
don't know now i can't wait to see
well your wife looks gorgeous tonight
we're close to the baby
very close a month away all right
okay did i ask you before did you know
what it do you know what it's gonna be
don't know what it is we're waiting
until the day oh my god how do you do
that
the only unpredictable thing left in
this world
everything else is so predictable don't
talk about how many jobs i got cause you
do
everything everything i'm gonna keep up
with you come on
have a good time okay good to see you
you